welcome to the last lecture where we are
going to be talking about the state of
the art in global illumination now if
you remember this scene you hopefully
also remember that we were able to
render caustics insanely fast with
metropolis light transport and the rest
of the scene is also cleaning up pretty
quickly but what about this this was a
not so difficult looking scene and you
can see that the Kellerman style
metropolis is doing pretty awful here
not even sure if it would converge if we
would wait for a very long time what the
problem is here is called SDS or
specular diffuse specular transport
let's talk about this for a bit so
imagine that I have a light path that
starts out from a light source hits this
glass object that is a specular bounce
and now it has another specular bounce
after the refraction then we hit a
diffuse object then the mirror and then
we hit the eye let's put up there
Hackbarth notation and let's rip out the
middle part of the light path now this
has SDS what is the intuition of this it
is reflected caustics because one s and
one D gives you caustics like we
discussed before and then if you have
another specular bounce then this says
that I am seeing the caustics through
the mirror the intuition for SDS light
paths is reflected caustics so what is
exactly the problem here imagine that we
start out from a diffused surface we
sample the brdf and therefore we arrive
to this other specular surface and off
of this specular surface we are supposed
to hit the pinhole camera also note that
this diffuse point on the surface was
chosen by the specular interaction
before and it was chosen explicitly now
you can hopefully see that this means
that depending on the material models if
we have perfect specular inter
reflections then sampling such a light
path is impossible
and this is a problem that you can
encounter very often because imagine
that if you have a light source that is
covered by a specular surface so for
instance a glass light bulb then even if
you have a regular D s path so one
diffuse and one specular bounce then you
add one more s because all the light
that is exiting the light source is
going to hit the cover the last part of
the light bulb and therefore every D s
is going to be SDS another image for the
intuition and better understanding of
what is exactly going on you can also
imagine that you are starting out a
light path from the light source and
from the eye and you have the SD from
the light source and you have the SS
from the eye now what you would like to
do is you would like to connect this
diffuse to the specular vertex now this
is impossible the specular vertex would
have to be chosen by the diffuse and the
diffuse brdf would be choosing one
outgoing direction on the hemisphere
uniformly sampled and it is only one
possible direction that we would be
happy with the probability of sampling
this one possible direction is exactly
the same as the probability of sampling
one point and that is zero so this is
the SDS problem and we are going to look
at biased algorithms that try to address
this problem so this looks like SDS to
me because we hit the glass cube that's
a specular bounce then we hit the
doughnut inside and then we hit the
glass cube again so this is SDS this is
why it is so difficult to sample with
metropolis light transport for our
mapping the key idea is that we don't
want to evaluate all possible light
paths what we would like to do is
sending photons out of light sources and
we're going to store all of these
photons in the map and when we are
computing actual light paths we are
going to rely on interpolation we are
going to use this knowledge that we have
in the photon map some visualization
images to get an idea how it exactly
looks
let's take a look at the first bounce
this is an image with only the very
first bounces in the path tracer this is
the directed light map now let's take a
look at the indirect light map this is
the second and higher-order bounces this
is basically indirect illumination color
bleeding and you can see that this is
actually low-frequency information you
can see that the colors don't really
seem to change so quickly if we have
indirect illumination this is a mostly
low frequency signal which lends itself
to the idea of interpolation this is an
example on how to use all this
information in the photo map so I would
be interested in the incident radiance
at the red dot and what I can do is use
the information from the nearby photons
and I would average all this information
to get an estimation for the red dot and
you can see that the brighter regions of
the image seem to have more photons in
the photon map why is that well it's
simple it's because we are shooting
photons out of the light sources and
these are the regions that are very
visible from the light source let's take
a look at some results you can see the
difficult scene rendered with path
tracing by directional path tracing is
much much better but you can still see
the Firefly noise we also have some
results with metropolis light transport
also doesn't help a lot with SDS
transport and photon mapping you can see
that all this high frequency noise is
gone but the result is slightly more
blurry than it should be because of the
interpolation we are averaging samples
and therefore this smoothing behavior is
inherent to that interpolation what are
the upsides of photon mapping while
caustics indirect illumination they
converge really quickly caustics why
because you have a lot of samples
because you see it from the light source
indirect illumination why because it's a
mostly low frequency signal that you can
interpolate very easily
note that it
also helps with the SDS problem because
of the interpolation you don't really
get high frequency noise for most cases
however don't forget that you may need
to shoot and store a lot of photons
depending on how complex your scene is
and this can be very computationally
intensive and also memory intensive and
interpolation can cause artifacts to
appear and this actually happens quite
often for more complex scenes because
you are looking up photons in the photo
map nearby
if these nearby forearms are on the same
object that you would like to query then
these are usually depending on textures
and and many other things this is
usually usable information but you are
looking up nearby photons and you may
see many examples in the room you're
sitting in where you have discontinuity
is nearby so there may be a wall that is
one color and there may be a wall nearby
at an intersection that is a different
color it may be that during the
interpolation you use samples from the
other wall because it is nearby and it
doesn't really take this property into
consideration so therefore artifacts may
appear what about this algorithm well we
are cutting corners we're using
interpolation we are not computing all
the possible light paths there are
therefore this algorithm has to be
biased what about the consistency well
it is consistent provided that you have
an infinite number of photons in the
photo map and therefore you always get
perfect information however this is only
of theoretical value because obviously
having an infinite number of photons may
make sense in a mathematical way but in
a practical implementation you cannot
even shoot and you cannot even store an
infinite number of photons some
literature this is the place where you
can look up the original photon mapping
paper from Henrique vannhansen some
delightful news this is an image I shot
at the euro graphic symposium of
rendering EGS our last year if you take
a look at these people you can see for
instance Voytek euros lead of the
rendering group at Disney research and
he and the EGS are or
neither crew gave out the test of time
award to Henri Funyuns and because of
the photo mapping algorithm it's been
around for a while and it had seen a lot
of use and it's a fantastic piece of
work and he got recognized for that